j'ai commencé un programme MBA à Harvard Business School.
Je faisais partie du petit pourcentage d'étudiants
avec une formation en programmation informatique.
Voici une photo de moi dans l'annuaire, assis au premier rang.
(Rires)
A Harvard, l'apprentissage est fondé sur des cas.
On en faisait trois par jour.
Il s'agit d'une douzaine de pages sur une situation précise d'affaires.
Il y a des tableaux, avec des mots et des nombres
disposés d'une certaine manière pour expliciter la situation.
Ils sont tous légèrement différents.
Voici mon devoir.
Des chiffres, des mots, mis en page pour créer du sens.
Des tonnes de calculs, nos calculettes n'étaient jamais loin.
Voici ma calculette, d'ailleurs.
Pour Halloween, je me suis déguisé en calculette.
(Rires)
Au début de chaque classe, le professeur appelait quelqu'un
pour présenter le cas.
Cette personne expliquait ce qu'il se passait
et dictait des informations que le professeur transcrivait
sur les nombreux tableaux noirs de la classe.
Ensuite nous en discutions.
Une des choses vraiment frustrantes quand on faisait ces devoirs,
était d'arriver le matin en classe pour découvrir une erreur de calcul,
qui faussait tous les autres chiffres.
Impossible de participer au débat.
Alors que nous étions notés sur notre participation.
Bref, parmi mes 87 collègues de classe, j'ai souvent eu le temps de rêver.
A l'époque la plupart des programmeurs travaillaient sur un ordinateur central,
construisant des systèmes d'inventaire, de fiches de paie ou de facturation.
J'avais bossé sur des traitements de texte interactifs
et de la programmation personnelle.
Au lieu de penser à tirer des impressions ou à des cartes perforées,
j'imaginais un tableau magique
qui, quand on effaçait un chiffre et le remplaçait par un autre,
ferait percoler ce changement partout automatiquement,
un traitement de texte des chiffres.
J'imaginais que ma calculette était équipée d'une souris
et d'un rétro-projecteur, comme un avion de combat.
Je pourrais alors encoder des chiffres, les entourer, pousser sur le bouton somme.
Je pourrais, au milieu d'une négociation, obtenir la réponse recherchée.
Il ne me restait plus qu'à concrétiser mon rêve.
Mon père m'avait appris à faire du prototypage.
Il m'avait montré des maquettes
qu'il créait pour visualiser la mise en page
des éléments de brochures qu'il devait imprimer.
Il utilisait les maquettes pour les montrer à ses clients
et obtenir leurs retours avant d'envoyer le bon à tirer.
En créant des versions simplifiées de ce qu'on souhaite créer,
on découvre obligatoirement des problèmes cruciaux.
Ce qui permet de leur trouver des solutions moins coûteuses.
J'ai donc décidé de créer un prototype.
Je me suis assis devant un terminal du système de temps partagé de Harvard
et je me suis mis au travail.
Un de mes premiers problèmes fut celui-ci :
Comment représenter des valeurs dans les formules ?
Je vais vous expliquer.
Je pensais ainsi : je pointe un endroit,
j'y écris quelques mots, et j'écris autre chose ailleurs,
j'ajoute un nombre et un nombre ailleurs, je pointe un endroit pour la réponse,
je pointe sur le premier, ensuite sur le moins, je pointe le second
et j'obtiens le résultat.
Voici mon problème : Que faut-il écrire dans la formule ?
Ça devait être compréhensible par l'ordinateur.
En lisant la formule,
il fallait savoir quels étaient ses référents sur l'écran.
Ma première idée fut d'organiser ça comme un programmeur.
Au moment de pointer un endroit,
l'ordinateur nous demande de taper un nom unique.
C'est clair que ce système allait vite devenir trop fastidieux.
Il fallait que l'ordinateur crée un nom automatiquement et l'assigne.
Ensuite, je me suis proposé de les nommer selon leur ordre d'écriture.
J'ai essayé ça. Valeur 1, valeur 2.
Je me suis aperçu qu'avec quelques valeurs supplémentaires,
j'allais oublier quels étaient les référents.
Alors j'ai pensé que, au lieu de pouvoir positionner ses valeurs n'importe où,
je pourrais délimiter un maillage.
Dans ce cas, on pointe une cellule
et l'ordinateur lui assigne comme nom sa ligne et sa colonne.
Et si je fais apparaître l'alphabet en abscisse et des chiffres en ordonnée,
quand vous visualisez B7 dans une formule,
vous savez précisément sa localisation sur l'écran.
Si vous devez taper une formule, vous savez comment faire.
Délimiter un maillage m'a aidé à résoudre mon problème.
Ça ouvrait aussi de nouvelles capacités, comme la sélection de plusieurs cellules.
Mais ce n'est pas trop contraignant
car on peut taper n'importe quelle valeur ou formule, dans toutes les cellules.
On fait toujours ainsi aujourd'hui, 40 ans plus tard.
Avec mon ami Bob, nous avons décidé de construire ce produit ensemble.
J'ai aussi travaillé pour comprendre comment le programme devait se comporter.
J'ai développé une carte de référence à titre de documentation.
Ça m'a permis de vérifier que l'interface que je développais
pouvait être expliquée de manière concise et claire à des gens normaux.
Bob a travaillé dans le grenier de son appartement, à Arlington.
En voici une photo.
Bob a acquis du temps sur le Multics du MIT,
pour écrire les codes, sur un terminal comme celui-ci.
Il téléchargeait des versions tests sur un Apple II emprunté,
via une ligne téléphonique, avec un coupleur acoustique,
et ensuite il testait.
Pour un de mes tests, j'ai utilisé le cas du Pepsi Challenge.
On ne pouvait pas encore imprimer, je prenais donc note de tout.
On ne pouvait pas sauvegarder. A chaque crash,
je devais retaper toutes les formules.
Le lendemain, j'ai levé la main au cours. On m'a désigné et j'ai présenté le cas.
J'avais préparé une projection sur 5 ans avec pleins de scénarios.
Je les ai complètement bluffés. VisiCalc était déjà utile.
Le professeur m'a demandé comment j'avais fait.
Je ne voulais pas lui dévoiler notre programme secret.
(Rires)
Je lui ai dit que j'avais additionné ça à ça, et multiplié par ça et retiré ça.
Il a demandé pourquoi je n'avais pas utilisé les ratios.
J'ai dit : « Ha ! Ça n'aurait pas été aussi exact. »
Je n'ai pas dit qu'on ne pouvait pas encore diviser.
(Rires)
Finalement, nous avons peaufiné VisiCalc suffisamment
pour le présenter au public.
Mon père a imprimé un modèle de carte de référence
à utiliser pour notre marketing.
En juin 1979, notre éditeur a annoncé VisiCalc publiquement,
dans un petit stand à la National Computer Conference à New York.
Le New York Times a écrit un article très drôle sur la conférence.
« Les machines réalisent une espèce de rite religieux...
Les croyants se rassemblent,
les peintres dans la salle du Colisée ajoutent un nom au panthéon,
en lettre jaunes et noires : « VISICALC ».
Hip Hip Hip Hourrah à VISICALC ! »
(Soupir) Le New York Times : « Hip Hip Hip Hourrah à VISICALC ! »
(Rires)
Ce fut la dernière mention des feuilles de calcul électroniques
dans la presse d'affaires populaire pendant 2 ans.
Presque personne n'avait compris.
Mais pas tous.
En octobre 1979, on a livré VisiCalc.
Il se vendait dans un emballage comme celui-ci.
Et sur un Apple II, ça donnait ceci.
La suite, comme on dit, fait partie de l'histoire.
Il y a tant d'autres choses à narrer,
mais ce sera pour un autre jour.
Une seule chose à ajouter : Harvard se souvient.
Voici ma classe.
Ils ont posé une plaque commémorative.
(Applaudissements)
Elle est aussi un rappel pour tous,
que nous devons utiliser nos cursus nos compétences et nos envies uniques
pour construire des prototypes pour découvrir et résoudre les problèmes
et, grâce à cela, changer le monde.
Merci.
(Applaudissements)